Traducteur: Elise LECAMP
Relecteur: eric vautier
Bonjour à tous.
Ça va ?
Ouah ! Ne vous inquiétez pas,
ça va être rapide.
(Rires)
Le 27 octobre 2005,
deux jeunes adolescents, Zyed et Bouna,
meurent électrocutés dans un poste EDF
en tentant d'échapper
à un contrôle de police.
Du coup, des jeunes de Clichy-sous-Bois
se soulèvent contre la police,
qui rétorque quelques jours plus tard
en envoyant une bombe lacrymogène
au pied d'une mosquée
en plein mois de ramadan.
S'ensuivent des émeutes
dans les quartiers,
d'abord dans le 9-3,
puis dans tous les quartiers de France.
J'avais à l'époque 19 ans,
et j'ai grandi en Seine-Saint-Denis
ainsi que toute ma famille,
une partie de mon enfance
et de mon adolescence.
Je me suis senti très concerné
par ce qui se passait
parce que comme une bonne partie
de ces jeunes
qui eux s'exprimaient par la violence,
j'étais moi-même issu de l'immigration
et je pouvais ressentir le malaise
qu'ils avaient vis à vis du système
ou de la France.
Ce qui m'a vraiment frappé à ce moment-là,
c'est le traitement
des médias à double tranchant.
D'un côté, le gamin que j'étais me disait,
tout le monde en parle.
Les pouvoirs publics ne vont pas
pouvoir ignorer la difficulté
qu'il y a en France, l'harmonie,
la problématique qu'on a à unifier
des Français qui sont divers
et notamment dans certains quartiers,
ces problématiques qui se sont accumulées
depuis des dizaines d'années
et que l’État n'arrive pas
et n'arrive toujours pas à endiguer.
De l'autre, en fait, c'était cette peur
en voyant semaine après semaine,
se poser une caricature
de cette fracture sociale
qui s'imposait comme une chape
de plomb sur la société,
ce dialogue de société
qui était dû notamment
au langage approximatif
d'abord employé par les médias
puis qui se répandait au niveau des gens
dans leur dialogue au quotidien.
On entendait parler de guerre civile.
Le terme improprement employé
était celui-là qui était répandu.
On entendait parler que la France
était à feu et à sang.
Pourtant, les quartiers concernés,
si on les additionne,
ne représenteraient
qu'à peine 0,01% du territoire.
On a même parlé à un moment
de révolte musulmane.
Bref, les approximations de langage
en fait qui composaient, qui polluaient
et qui perturbent le dialogue de société,
se retrouvaient au niveau
des gens et a fortiori,
dans une société diverse,
créaient une complexité.
J'ai vu au fil des semaines,
se poser
une rhétorique implicite
du « eux » contre « nous »
avec deux camps.
D'un côté, plutôt une population
qui serait blanche, conservatrice,
au moins, voire raciste,
et qui aurait un intérêt à entretenir
des plafonds de verre
et le système discriminatoire
l'arrangerait, donc le maintenir.
De l'autre côté,
une population immigrée
qui serait soit fainéante
et/ou génétiquement violente
et qui bien entendu soit porte le voile,
la capuche et --
mesdames et messieurs bien sûr --
la fameuse
casquette
à l'envers.
Le dialogue de société,
perturbé
comme il l'était à ce moment-là,
était non seulement offensant,
offensant pour les uns
comme pour les autres.
D'autant plus que nous devons
faire face à deux défis.
Le premier, c'est celui de la diversité.
Nos sociétés sont diverses
et vont l'être de plus en plus,
qu'on le veuille ou non.
L'explosion des flux migratoires,
nous-mêmes étudiants en France,
on a la chance de pouvoir partir
facilement en Erasmus à l'étranger,
et pourquoi pas ? s'expatrier, y vivre.
De même, on peut venir
chez nous plus facilement
mais cet enjeu n'est pas seulement
l'enjeu qui se passe en France,
c'est l'enjeu
pour toutes les sociétés du monde
et c'est un mouvement
avec lequel il va falloir dealer.
Le second événement historique
auquel nous assistons --
je ne veux pas parler
du 4e titre consécutif
que le PSG va remporter cette année...
Zlatan, si tu nous entends,
paix à ton âme, plutôt.
Je veux parler bien entendu
de la crise d'Internet.
Les remaniements qui sont dus
à l'essor et à l'explosion du numérique,
de l'ère du réseau,
où chaque domaine de la société
est frappé et remis en question
par les valeurs collaboratives,
participatives,
qui bien sûr ouvrent un champ
des possibles incroyable
mais aussi ouvrent une ère de doute
et de remise en question.
Il était beaucoup plus facile
pour le Général de Gaulle
posé devant l'ORTF à 20h,
pendant que les Français buvaient leur
soupe de nous raconter le récit national
et de nous raconter
la grandeur de la France
et de créer quelque part du lien social.
Aujourd'hui nous sommes potentiellement
7,5 milliards chaînes d'information
capables d'émettre de l'information
et d'en recevoir.
On est passé en somme
d'une société à voix dominante
à une société à voix multiples
où tous peuvent s'exprimer.
L'agora 2.0 pour ne pas dire l'agora 3.0,
en réalité,
est une agora où
on n'est plus réellement représenté
par une petite partie de personnes
qui parlent au nom de tout le monde
mais bien de 7,5 milliards
de personnes potentielles
qui ont leur avis, leurs idées,
leur créativité, leurs notions
mais aussi leurs violences,
leur ras-le-bol.
Aujourd'hui,
tout ça est un phénomène nouveau.
On est aussi dans cette génération
face à cet essor des personnes
qui peuvent s'exprimer
dans une culture du clash.
La parole est devenue
assimilée au conflit.
C'est l'ère des trolleurs,
des haters, de la provoc,
pour faire des vues, des likes,
attirer sur sa page.
C'est même devenu une stratégie politique,
une stratégie un peu offensive,
de poser des punchlines.
C'est devenu le code.
La parole est devenue un sport
presque de combat,
obligée dans le temps court
pour attirer les gens
par peur, pour attirer la peur.
C'est le sensationnel qui nous permet
de nous faire entendre.
En réalité, c'est même une stratégie.
C'est comme ça que les émissions
de télé sont faites.
On cultive cette culture du sensationnel
et qui est en train,
dans l'inconscient collectif,
de structurer la parole
à un sport de combat.
En réalité,
tout le monde peut prendre la parole,
mais on ne s'écoute plus vraiment.
Dans ce brouhaha,
je me suis posé la question ;
à un moment donné, je me suis dit :
« Comment recréer,
dans la société, des espaces
où la communication,
le dialogue, pourraient se faire
de manière profonde,
sincère et constructive ? »
En 2012, je me suis rendu
à l'université de Seine-Saint-Denis
pour y créer deux choses :
un concours de prise de parole en public
et plus tard, une année après,
une formation
à la prise de parole en public.
Ce concours,
ces programmes dits « Eloquentia »
consistaient en deux temps.
Le premier : un concours ouvert
à tous les jeunes de Seine-Saint-Denis
entre 18 et 30 ans
qui peuvent venir
et défendre le propos qu'ils souhaitent,
que ce soit une idée, leur créativité,
s'ils ont envie de tenir une parole
de colère contre la société.
Tout le monde peut s'exprimer
que ce soit en rap, slam, alexandrins,
prose, discours, peu importe
dès lors que ce que tu viens
nous dire est sincère.
Très rapidement, des dizaines de jeunes,
dès la première année,
ont participé au concours.
On a eu des amphithéâtres pleins à craquer
et pourtant on était en plein cœur du 9-3
et dans la société on avait déjà
une crispation sur la liberté d'expression
qui se mettait en place,
en décalage complet avec ce qui se passait
en plein cœur
de la Seine-Saint-Denis.
Le deuxième programme était une formation
à la prise de parole en public
pour travailler sur la confiance en soi
et justement travailler la parole
avec un collectif, en groupe.
Une formation
qui s'articule sur cinq temps :
le premier, c'est travailler sur la prise
de parole en milieu professionnel.
On leur demande :
« Quel est ton rêve ?
Que veux-tu faire ? »
On s'adapte sur 60 heures
de semaine en semaine
à les accompagner, à leur donner les codes
pour pouvoir aller au bout de leur rêve.
Le second point : structurer la pensée,
structurer le discours.
C'est la partie
un peu plus aristotélicienne,
le discours d'Aristote :
l’exorde, une intro, l'argumentation,
la réfutation, la péroraison.
Structurer la pensée.
Troisième temps : un rapport.
La parole n'est pas uniquement
quelque chose de personnel.
C'est ce qu'on fait
avec un groupe, avec les autres.
Comprendre pourquoi est-ce que
là mon cœur,
juste avant de rentrer,
battait à 2 000 à l'heure ?
Le comprendre, gérer son stress,
le positionnement de son corps,
appréhender, en fait, le rapport
aux autres au-delà du simple fait
de parler et d'interagir avec les autres.
Le reste, c'était
de travailler sur la créativité.
Aller vers des prises de paroles
différentes par le slam, la poésie,
le théâtre,
qui permettent l'introspection,
la remise en question
et essayer d'appréhender la parole
sous de nouveaux codes.
Très rapidement,
on a obtenu des résultats dingues
dès la première année.
Des dizaines de participants.
L'événement est devenu un événement
référencé en Seine-Saint-Denis
où des jeunes pas uniquement
de l'université,
d'ailleurs jamais de l'université,
assistaient aux battles.
En ce qui concerne la formation,
il y avait un phénomène particulier
qui se créait :
quand les jeunes parlaient,
ils venaient, ils s'ouvraient aux autres
mais d'abord à eux-mêmes.
Dans ce cadre très intime,
en s'ouvrant aux autres,
il y avait une empathie,
un collectif capable
d'aborder tous les sujets
et de co-construire une réflexion,
pas toujours de changer d'avis,
mais en tout cas d'évoluer
et de s'enrichir les uns les autres.
En 2015, pour la deuxième année
de la formation,
comme on était à contre-courant
avec ce qu'il se passait dans la société,
j'ai décidé de réaliser un film
qui suivrait le plus fidèlement
possible ce qu'il se passait
au niveau de la formation et du concours.
En suivant ces jeunes ordinaires,
-- 22 000 jeunes
à l'université de Saint-Denis,
et 25 000 à côté,
à l'université de Villetaneuse,
50 000 jeunes
qui ne sont pas tous de banlieue
mais pour beaucoup
d'entre eux oui,
qui ont intelligence, créativité,
des propos, des militantismes,
qui, au demeurant,
dans cette ère collective
sont indispensables pour refaire société.
Mettre la lumière sur eux,
suivre ce qu'il se passait.
Et à la fois, ils avaient
une dimension extraordinaire
parce que pendant 60 heures,
ils venaient le samedi
de 9h30 à 19h30 pour se battre,
pour être accompagnés,
pour qu'on les accompagne
à dire ce qu'ils avaient
à apporter à la société
et qu'ils aillent au bout de leurs rêves,
professionnels notamment.
Le premier jour de tournage,
c'était le 7 janvier 2015.
La première fois qu'on les a filmés,
au même moment,
la France entamait l'apogée de sa crise
sur la liberté d'expression.
Les attentats de Charlie Hebdo justement,
et les six semaines suivantes,
pendant que toute la société se tendait,
que le dialogue de société était
vraiment très très compliqué,
à nouveau une famille se formait,
était capable d'aborder tous les sujets
y compris celui de Charlie Hebdo,
dans une dimension de respect,
d'écoute mutuelle et de co-construction.
Le film s'appelle « À voix haute ».
Je vous propose de regarder
un court extrait.
J'ai dit ce que je pensais.
Quand j'ai parlé des cordes arrachées,
je l'ai vraiment pensé
quand tu l'as dit.
Je voyais la scène...
- Ça ne m'a pas blessée.
- OK Cool.
Si ça blesse l'autre,
on ne peut pas rire de tout.
Il faut s'adapter à la situation inverse
Si ça le bloque, ce n'est peut-être
pas un manque de respect
mais c'est délicat de rire
de ça devant lui.
Comment tu fais
pour savoir que ça le bloque ?
Oui c'est ça...
En fait, tout le monde
a une sensibilité différente.
Il faudrait une limite pour
chaque personne, ce n'est pas possible.
On peut avoir
des sensibilités différentes,
si on a la culture de l'autodérision.
On peut rire de tout en France.
Si on s'attaque
à une autre culture,
il faut faire attention.
Si tu dis : « C'est du domaine privé,
on n'y touche pas,
C'est une autre culture,
on ne peut pas en rigoler. »
Si on commence comme ça,
on arrête l'humour.
L'humour, c'est un combat.
La parole, c'est un combat, une arme.
Je pense et j'ai envie de faire
des blagues
qui vont dans mon sens.
Je sais qu'en face,
il y en a qui ne pensent pas comme moi.
Dieudonné, je le déteste.
Je suis très content
qu'il puisse s'exprimer.
Je vais utiliser mon humour,
ma parole pour le combattre.
On a tous des sujets qu'on n'aborde pas,
d'autres qu'on aborde.
Je n'empêche personne de le faire
mais personnellement,
je sais que si je vais blesser,
je ne le ferais pas.
Si j'ai le choix de blesser ou non,
On fait tous les hypocrites.
C'est pas possible.
On va tous rire.
On le sait très bien,
il y a des choses dont on va rire.
Mais quand ça nous vise,
on va en pleurer.
Toute cette histoire, c'est un travail
qu'il faut faire sur nous-mêmes.
Faut qu'on arrête d'être hypocrite.
Personnellement, j'ai dépassé ce stade.
Je peux rire de moi.
Il n'y a pas de problème.
Si mes parents meurent et
qu'on fait une blague,
si je la trouve drôle,
je vais rire, c'est sadique
complètement fou,
mais moi si ça me fait rire, je ris.
Sinon, je ne ris pas.
Je ne vais pas faire une polémique.
Faut arrêter d'être hypocryte
au bout d'un moment.
Vivre et laisser vivre.
S'il y en a qui veulent en rire,
qu'ils en rient.
Fraise ?
(Applaudissements)
Merci beaucoup.
Le message que j'aimerais
vous faire passer en fait,
c'est que dans cette crise,
dans cette ère à multiples voix
dans laquelle nous vivons,
on est capable de se parler
et aussi de se comprendre.
On a obtenu des résultats
qui valent ce qu'ils valent.
On est depuis 4 ans
à 1 000 étudiants formés.
Cette année, on va passer
entre 800 et 1 500 jeunes
qui vont être concernés
par notre programme.
Le Conseil Général de Seine-Saint-Denis
nous laisse travailler sur 50 collèges
pour initier les jeunes
à la prise de parole
et l'importance de la parole citoyenne
et de les impliquer dans la vie
de leur établissement.
Le concours Eloquentia a commencé
à Nanterre, à Grenoble, à Limoges.
Mais j'ai envie de dire,
on est sur quatre universités,
il en existe 72 potentiellement.
On a travaillé
avec 1 000 jeunes jusqu'ici.
Il en existe des millions
qui seraient prêts et qui le sont,
c'est leur montée de terrain.
Génération métissée, interconnectée,
les Millenials ont ça dans leur ADN.
Ils n'attendent que ça, qu'on offre
des cadres éthiques, sains.
Ça passe bien entendu
par les institutions.
L'Éducation Nationale s'empare du sujet
sur les questions de prise de parole.
Mais il faut continuer.
C'est d'ailleurs à mon sens,
l'enjeu prioritaire de société,
avant même d'essayer de nous convaincre
d'être socialiste, d'être libéraux ;
d'essayer de nous convaincre
d'être de gauche, de droite,
avant même d'essayer
de nous convaincre
qu'il faut peut-être travailler plus,
peut-être participer plus
par l'impôt au nom d'un idéal commun.
Le préalable, c'est comment
on réapprend à communiquer
dans cette ère à multiples voix
qui donne le vertige
et comment on recrée un espace
et des conditions d'un dialogue collectif
qui va permettre de co-construire
à nouveau une identité citoyenne commune.
Alors comme le dit Eddy dans le film,
il faut qu'on bosse sur nous-même.
Ça concerne toutes les personnes
de la société sans exception.
Les riches, les pauvres,
les gens des banlieues,
les gens de la ville,
toutes les religions, les musulmans,
les juifs, les catholiques,
les bouddhistes,
tout le monde est concerné.
C'est d'abord pour réussir
ce défi collectif de société,
c'est d'abord
une révolution personnelle
qu'on doit entamer sur nous-même
puis dans notre cercle familial,
puis avec nos potes, au boulot,
et c'est uniquement par ce biais-là,
et si on prend conscience
de l'urgence de cela
que l'on peut refaire société
collectivement
et les institutions accompagneront.
Mais c'est d'abord une prise de conscience
qu'on doit faire individuellement.
Je signe chacune de mes œuvres
par un maillon
parce que j'appartiens moi-même
à une chaîne,
à laquelle nous appartenons tous.
Nous sommes la génération la plus
interconnectée de l'Histoire.
En vrai, on est ensemble.
Nos vies, nos destins, sont liés
les uns aux autres.
Apprenons simplement maintenant
à en parler.
Merci à tous.
(Applaudissements)